you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm going to do a
few puzzles from tactics trainer on
chess comm and before I go into each of
these puzzles feel free to pause the
video and see if you can figure out the
solution before I just go ahead and
share my thoughts in how I approach each
puzzle so let's get going let's try this
first one which is black to play so
let's see what are my thoughts here well
the first thing that I'm noticing is
that there's the possibility to get at
this C 2 square and I'm recognizing that
the Queen is restricted in some way and
that I could be playing rook to c8 and
after the Queen moves Knight takes pawn
however there is Queen takes bishop but
I believe at the end of it grabbing upon
and a rook is going to be good enough I
don't know that this one is much more
involved actually it is hang on for a
second because after rook c8 there's
Queen takes Knight so this is something
I need to be considering it rook c8
there's Queen takes Knight there goes my
idea of a fork hmm oh I am however
seeing something right now okay I think
I have the answer this is a little bit
tricky hair so this rook if I could just
capture this pawn then the rook here is
going to be trapped it you can't move
and so I don't necessarily have to come
here on the c2 square with check so I'm
seeing a way that I could remove the
defender of c2 in a very forceful way
with Queen to e6 Queen e6 forking the
Queen and the king and after Queen takes
Queen I don't recapture the Queen right
away but first capture the pawn with
check the King must go here and then
after recapture with the bishop or the
pawn the rook is gonna be dead so I
think that's the solution Queen b6 that
is the correct move
and I believe I take here tonight takes
on this square first and that is in fact
the solution so the little time around
the bottom is something that I'm not too
concerned about but uh I'm just trying
to find the best move so let's just dive
right into the next problem it's just
two more and this one it's white to play
so let's see and this right here this
little 330 seconds it gives you some
indication of the difficulty level so
okay white to move and probably win this
isn't one of those the best you can do
is draw type of positions so how can
white go ahead and do better here how
can white win hmm first thing I'm
noticing is that well the black Queen
doesn't have any checks so on whites and
this next move here for white it could
be a quiet move it doesn't necessarily
have to pack a strong punch it doesn't
necessarily have to give check this is
my first thought actually not that Queen
here is my first thought it's it's very
forcing but I also am considering f5
since it's threatening a mate in one
with Queen here seems like it's tough to
defend let's let's see here for a second
it's probably has to be one of those two
f5 or Queen to e2 after Queen e2 Queen
blocks what's that what's a good follow
up and it's also important to take a
quick tally here point wise white is
down upon so it's most likely not a good
idea to be welcome to trades Queen e2
Queen here then all of a sudden you have
to deal with you know the g3 pond so
that's that's probably not the way to go
it seems like this is the correct answer
f5 what I have any other candidate moves
I don't know about
hmm interesting so okay after f5 if
black plays here g5 ah okay I'm seeing
it then then Queen here is okay because
you could exchange and then advance
you'd end up with the past pun so I
think after f5 how do you defend against
Queen f4 mate not really a good solution
to that not a good response so I believe
that is it f5 no black Queen checks
after f5 just double checking here f5 if
g5 then Queen here there could be King
takes pawn hang on for a second hang on
for a second f5 g5
then you just maybe push u6 then there
you have to watch out for eventual Queen
checks the Queen maybe be moving and get
to see - hmm I could always just not
calculate all the way through that's one
of the one of the tricks you could be
using for these puzzles here you don't
necessarily have to see the variations
in depth I believe that this must be the
only first move so I could always just
make that move right now
and then see what the reply will be and
then have a look at that position but
I'm really trying to calculate this one
through to its end from this initial
position I am pretty much locked in on
the f5 f5 g5 then hmm then I'm kind of
stuck I'm not sure is there's some some
way to kind of track down the Queen some
tactic to win the black queen she is
unprotected but I don't see some sort of
a trick to get the Queen so f5 g5 v g5
and then
hmmm I wonder if it would be e six I
think that must be the way to go just
get this pond marching then I go with
that it is the correct move oh I didn't
even consider king takes all right so
what's that what's the deal here
okay so I'm definitely not seeing this
one through to its end but uh I think
you just have to go hunting this King
down now how do you get that King
there's not gonna be any stalemate trick
there's too many white pawns that could
be moving so Queen f4 King here Queen f6
King here and the follow-up I'm just not
seeing it wow what is going on here
Queen f4 Queen f2 they both give check
but what it what is the story with this
one huh I am really stumped I don't know
Queen f4 King here Queen f6 came here
he's running away there's no way I'm
catching that king so what could
possibly be the answer here pawn push oh
hang on hang on for a second pawn push
might be it yeah it must be it he's six
that is sneaky took me long enough ecigs
and if the Queen or pawn takes Queen
here is mate this is the King's only
safe square that's gotta be it it is it
ah so the Queen continues to run she is
officially scared I could push that
again I could give check but that's not
gonna be it King takes pawn so I believe
okay now now I'm down to two options at
this point take the pawn or push I think
you take the pawn here which is then
threatening promotion followed by Queen
f4 and take the Queen and the other
option would be what
mmm take the pawn and I'm threatening
yeah that seems good enough actually
take the pawn and I just have the threat
of a check and then promotion so I think
I take here yeah I think that's it and
it is and now just this is where I think
you could come up as it might say
incorrect move but I believe there will
be three good options I'm just I'm just
gonna play 2f2 cuz it's gonna stop any
checks no no no hang on for a second
that's not the case because after I
checked the King plays here so I do have
to be accurate after after a check
there's gonna be a king here which is
defending the promotion so let me be a
little bit careful here Queen here there
is one check and then after King h3
there's not a good check next so I think
that's it so you play Queen here there's
Queen d2 King h3 the Queen has a check
on d7 but my queen will be there to stop
it so I believe that this is the last
key move Queen there and it is correct
the check and I believe you just go here
because I will be promoting with check
necks getting a new queen and that's it
took me long enough but let's see if we
could go three for three
all right last problem here we go okay
let's let's go with this white to move
and most likely win yeah there's not
gonna be any draw or a perpetual check
as far as I could tell and the first
thing that I'm seeing is that this King
is running very short on squares I'm
looking at the forcing moves rook here
check King here's the only reply I'm
looking at this is the candidate move
right here and also one quiet move pawn
here which would be then be threatening
a million-one
so hmm
all right rook check King here let's go
with the force we'll move first rook
this is how I'm approaching this problem
I'm trying to solve this puzzle rook to
b8 check King a6 pawn push check there
could be a capture recapture King here
hmm oh you know what it is there's one
little quiet move
I think it's rook check King here and
then Bishop to d2 there's not a knight
move that could give check there's a
rook move that could give check in a
couple different spots but neither is
going to help black to win the game yeah
I think it's rook check King here and
then Bishop d2 which would be
threatening a million-two with pawn push
the rook would be covering here and the
other variation would be to play b5
first with this threat of rook to b8 but
after a pawn move I don't know how to
really defend against well I don't know
how to continue since there would be a
new square available for the king so I
believe it is this check first I'm gonna
run with it it is correct and now I
think if you do this immediately the
King runs away and you're not really
able to track them down so I think now
is the time for one quiet move I think I
could afford that Bishop d2 there's rook
takes pawn you're just you're just
winning material there's a rook check
here after king c2 the same thread is
there and after Bishop d2 of pawn push
keep in mind I could take twice and
that'll actually be me with just the
rook and pawn here on b5 yeah I think
that's it Bishop to d2 one quiet move
and it is in fact correct so and then we
have this sort of trick you just grab
the material and that
in fact the to solve the problem
surprisingly enough I don't do very well
with these problems so I don't know
I'm not definitely not going to always
be going three for three but I in this
particular video but uh that's pretty
much it feel free to share how you do
with tactics puzzles and do they help
you with your progress in the game let
me know in the comments section below
and as always I hope you got something
out of this video take care bye
you